if you snored we wouldn't have dated in
the first always we went to college
together we you know started hooking up
started dating it was a long six months
just like this to me a long day and
we're very different like there's a lot
of like things that you know kind of got
in the way of things on yeah not really
different what really happened I don't
even remember totally what happened yeah
like well I know that I know that I was
moving across the country to study
abroad for like a couple months so that
was like time distance you can't really
trust me I felt like no yeah that's that
that was like well you are knowing
you're like well known at our school for
being a player they're gonna say that I
doubt that so we're gonna have to make
some sacrifices you're yeah I mean it's
a Saturday you're a big party animal and
I'm not that makes me a little nervous
because I know how you are when you go
out what about getting dressed I'm kinda
looking forward to that
we're putting this on my left hand cuz I
need my right hand free this is this is
one of the biggest issues she's
controlling like why do you get your
dominant hand because I need to teach a
yoga class I need to write an essay also
I'd put makeup on you don't you know I
need my right hand for more things than
you do let's go it's good
locked ends maybe 24 hours starts now
[Music]
alright it is time for weekly yoga that
I teach thank you so much for being here
let's just start we're right where we
are in a comfortable seated position you
just start to settle in here one more
inhale deep breath out deep breath in
interlace your hands behind your back
she always takes forever to order
I wasn't we did you know now
how did you change well I hooked up with
way less people you're not in like sort
of a climb so we are about to go to a
public park to lay in the Sun get some
rain but there are a lot of people here
and I've never been more uncomfortable
and I offered to take a picture for
these nice people that have bees over
there this is like being green why don't
I do this for my hands this is a hand
towel it needs to be your towel this
well I know you stole this from who we
dated we we got to get into our bathing
suits over nice we're just letting the
love show and then we're gonna get some
rays
[Music]
they drained this whole bottle of water
that was a mistake where are you gonna
pee well we're gonna we're gonna go on
the same bathroom together
we just got home to a beautiful sunset
we're home or about to start cooking
[Music]
everything's a disaster now will is
holding but I think the medaka bottle as
he could cause he burns his thumb so
apparently I wasn't cleaning everything
right
yeah you were clean I don't burn fuel
line and use Cleveland dishes with cold
[ __ ] water
we're in a hurry I don't know the board
it doesn't need to be spit shine which
needs to be like kind of clean did your
cleaning digits with cold water so I
thought you took over okay I need to get
to the bar okay like we want zero yoga I
live in to the park that's cool we got
your pesto now I need to drink and go to
the bar starting to be like this is all
about Skye's world and I'm just attached
here god I do see your like silhouette
of a body where he tells they over there
it's cold didn't see my nads did you
guys been doing her makeup for no idea
how long let's see what you have to do
to get ready well all right we're in the
Oberon route 2 boys night
Easy's via Horizonte and I'm doing boys
night for you
yo is that a yawn and boy so the big
issue was was I gonna like survive
tonight Luke who didn't survive well
wake up wake up wake up
you've been up for the past 40 minutes
waiting for you to wake up he's lying
here look at all of the day this is
terrible this that was the worst nights
that you've ever had we didn't at all
this I slept a little bit shut up don't
nothing happens I swear you want to tell
what happened when we got home from the
bar Scott nothing happens asleep yeah
nothing nothing I think you're gonna
miss me after we uncuffed I miss you a
little bit we just bicker a lot cuz we
just disagree about a lot of things I
think it's good to expose yourself to
people and to spend time with people who
have different beliefs in media you
learn a lot about somebody and I think I
learned the little things about you
which I didn't already know we already
knew you were fun person to be around
that's why I liked you the first place
and I think going through all the
challenges together it just made us work
as a team if we were forced to work as a
team and we were a good team you're a
good team yeah I just need some I just
need my right arm back oh my gosh okay I
know all right well get out of my house
yeah like dried fruit look just figure
something prunes gets bad I get P shy
and so usually what happens and I
promise in the music beaver song as far